[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la copa de
la FIFA Qatar 2022 a continuación
nuestros titulares
Lionel Messi apareció en un momento
importante guión a Argentina una sufrida
pero necesario Victoria frente a México
en la segunda fecha del grupo c David
Celeste sigue con vida y deja a México
en una posición complicada tenemos
análisis
Francia rompió el maleficio los
dirigidos portiriar de champs vencieron
a Dinamarca y se clasificaron a los
octavos de final de la presidenta
edición de la Copa del Mundo kylian
mbappé fue la figura para Los Galos que
tienen posibilidades de cerrar como
primeros del grupo
el jugador polaco robar lewandowski
anotó en la victoria de su selección
contra la representación de Arabia
Saudita El Triunfo le permite a los
blanquirrojos soñar con alcanzar los
octavos de final de este torneo a
distancia a la que no llegan desde la
Copa del Mundo de 1986
y para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio saso periodista de la emisora
Blu radio en Colombia bienvenido Octavio
Hola Luis un gusto saludarte como
siempre También aprovecho darle la
bienvenida a nuestro enviado especial
Juan pupiales que nos trae todos los
detalles de primera mano de lo que está
ocurriendo en
Qatar saludos Juan
Hola Luis Octavio un placer verdadero un
verdadero partidazo el que vivimos hoy y
además entre dos elecciones
latinoamericanas ya vamos a estar
hablando de eso Juan porque fue un
partido esperado por gran parte de
América Latina la selección de Argentina
venció a México en la segunda fecha del
grupo c el partido venía tomando
ambiente desde hace algunos días debido
a la necesidad de los dos conjuntos por
conseguir un buen resultado y ello
derivó el enfrentamientos entre hinchas
de ambas selecciones en Qatar y a través
de las redes sociales la victoria
Argentina les obliga ahora a vencer a la
selección de Polonia para clasificarse Y
por qué no pelear por el primer lugar de
este grupo pero Juan cómo se vivió ese
Triunfo de Argentina de 2 por 0 frente a
la selección de México
sin duda alguna uno de los partidos más
más vibrantes sino el partido más
vibrante que hemos visto en este en este
mundial de Qatar 2022 desde que llegamos
esta vez se respiró fútbol en este
estadio del estadio de luz ahí ese
estadio va a ser el estadio de la final
de este mundial hoy demostró que está
hecho para las grandes citas
88.000.966 espectadores la cifra de
asistencia más alta en un mundial en la
historia desde la final del mundial de
Estados Unidos en 1994 Yo diría que a
partes iguales se dividieron las
hinchadas en mexicanas y argentinas
intercambiaban cánticos de lado y lado
hubo un ambiente Una atmósfera muy
bonita además como pueden ver este ese
estadio es un estadio que tiene cuenta
con una arquitectura bastante llamativa
una iluminación muy bonita Hoy demostró
que pudo albergar Una atmósfera para un
partido digno un partido que eso sí
digamos ganó emoción sobre todo en la
segunda parte la primera parte yo creo
que ambos equipos saltaron con mucho
respeto era una final para los dos de
hecho lo acaba de decir Lionel Messi en
sus redes sociales en instagram Ya acaba
de poner un post en el que dijo que
queda todavía otra finales al final
contra Polonia para Argentina volviendo
al partido cinco cambios y solo en el
escalón y para este encuentro y ya hizo
otros cinco cambios antes del minuto 70
demostrando que le está costando un poco
encontrar con la línea para este
encuentro México que le disputó digamos
la pelota al comienzo de en los primeros
45 minutos Argentina sobre todo de la
mano de un Herrera que tuvo muy
controlado a Messi pero para el segundo
periodo de Argentina salió mucho más
conectada y esa presión de los mexicanos
se fue diluyendo figura clave además de
Messi yo lo pondría a la altura la de
Enzo Fernández El mediocentro del
benfica que ingresó para este segundo
periodo y le cambió la cara Argentina
dándole más toque en el medio de campo y
permitiendo que Messi conectará mucho
más con la medular además para conservar
consagrarse terminó haciendo un golazo
del 2 a 0 para después de ese primer
tanto de Messi que también fue una
bonita obra de arte apareció el 10 que
además llega a 8 goles llega a 8 goles
los mismos que ocho goles en los
mundiales en los mismos que consiguió
Diego Armando Maradona en la copa mundo
Argentina así como decimos todavía juega
se juega la vida contra Polonia
Octavio lo adelantaba a Juan el partido
quizás tuvo un primer tiempo muy
complicado Juan lo planteaba de mucho
respeto y a mí me pareció más que hubo
mucha atención pero era lo que esperaban
los seleccionadores ese juego
disputándose en la mitad de la cancha
con pocas llegadas a ambos costados de
la misma Luis Gerardo martino sorprendió
a todos por la forma en Cómo planteó
sobre todo ese primer tiempo por la
forma en como paró el equipo la gente en
México y los que hemos visto a México a
lo largo de la última eliminatoria en
Concacaf digamos no nos parece una
sorpresa la forma en Cómo en cómo lo
encaró evidentemente él en algún momento
del partido Gerardo martino sobre todo
Estaba tratando de Buscar el empate a
cero tratando de resolver ese resultado
de esa manera y evitando la derrota que
lo dejaba último de grupo Sin embargo a
medida que fueron pasando los minutos el
partido se fue digamos haciendo mucho
más más duro más complicado y la
ansiedad sobre todo el lago argentino
que era el equipo más necesitado fue
marcando la diferencia en batido porque
lo obligó a retroceder a equivocarse a
tener imprecisiones Rodrigo de Polo jugó
un muy mal primer tiempo y eso
desencadenó en lo que terminó pasando en
el cierre de los primeros 45 pero luego
en la segunda mitad de Luis apareció el
El Talento individual y Messi Se sacó un
peso de encima Para para marcar el 1 a 0
que luego derivó en la en la victoria de
los tres puntos de hecho Octavio en lo
que me respecta vi a un Messi más
calmado y más relajado después de ese
gol que es lo que fue la primera parte
del partido frente a México luego de esa
derrota frente a Arabia Saudita
avanzamos porque desde la copa del mundo
del año 2006 celebrada en Alemania
ningún campeón vigente había logrado
avanzar a los octavos de final de hecho
fue en esa copa del mundo cuando vimos
al último con Brasil campeón en Corea y
Japón que clasificó y fue eliminado en
cuartos de final pero cuatro años más
tarde fue Italia emparejado en el grupo
F y que quedó en el cuarto lugar de su
grupo luego le tocaría España en la copa
de Brasil en 2014 cuando cayó en el
grupo B sufrió una goleada de Países
Bajos y quedó eliminado a quedar
terceros en su llave en Rusia le tocó
Alemania campeón en Brasil emparejado en
el grupo F y que quedó en cuarta
posición de su grupo por ello sumado a
la gran cantidad de ausencias por lesión
había mucha expectativa en torno Al
conjunto que dirige didier de champs
pero Octavio una victoria de Francia un
partido complicado por momentos ya que
Dinamarca que parecía que tenía las
herramientas para extender Esta racha
que lleva de no perder frente a Francia
si digamos que el partido se resume Luis
y amigos de Franz 24 en una palabra
jerarquía la jerarquía de kilian mbappé
fue él el que termina resolviendo el
partido el que termina rompiendo esa
digamos eso que había propuesto
Dinamarca Dinamarca hay que decirlo Luis
venía de ganarle la liga de Naciones a
Francia es decir Dinamarca entendía
perfectamente Cómo al campeón del mundo
no le temía la posibilidad de digamos
poder tener un partido mano a mano con
Los Galos de todas maneras es muy
difícil digamos en medio de ese juego en
el que tú estás tratando de defenderte
constantemente y con alguna salida a
buscar la posibilidad de marcar un gol
como lo hizo Dinamarca es muy difícil
también tener los ojos puestos sobre
mbappé que al final mbappé cuando pasa a
la segunda velocidad termina marcando
diferencia y es lo que hace que el que
el partido se decante por ahí Francia no
es que jugó un partido brillante ni ni
mucho menos pero aprovechó las
posibilidades que le dio Dinamarca para
sacarlos la ventaja y el resultado
insisto fue en el momento en el que
decidió mbappé incluso con el partido
uno a uno cuando él decidió termina
marcando la diferencia y por eso Francia
Hoy está tranquilamente en octavos de
final ahora quisiera ir a todos a para
hablar con Juan porque Más allá de la
actuación de kilian mbappé que otros
detalles fueron claves para la victoria
y la clasificación de Francia en este
copa del mundo
Antes de hablar de esas figuras son
datos sobre mbappé tiene 23 años y lleva
siete goles en los mundiales Eso habla
mucho siguiendo en la línea con lo decía
Octavio de la calidad que tiene este
jugador además de Killer mbappé yo
destacaría mucho lo de tío Hernández
bendita lesión la de su hermano
Lucas Hernández que le permitió al ser
titular theo Hernández viene siendo uno
de los mejores laterales izquierdos
rosas de Europa lo está haciendo con el
Milán y en esta copa mundo está
demostrando que está quizás en el mejor
momento desde su carrera figura clave en
la ofensiva y en la defensiva de Francia
además también destacar mucho hoy el
partido también de radio jugadores del
que ya hemos hablado que estuvo apartado
por su propia Mala conducta ahora está
demostrando que es un jugador llamado y
que tiene una muy buena calidad Para
aportar a ese centro del campo tan mi
armado sin incolocante sin Paul Pogba
figuras clave en Rusia 2018 destacar
sobre todo es que volvió Rafael varane
El capitán de la defensa de Francia Hoy
estuvo acompañado de upa americano y es
la figura que da mucha confianza a la
saga francesa porque como decimos es uno
de sus Pilares es un jugador además muy
experimentado muy buenas sensaciones a
las que deja Francia y como estamos
indicando que le permite a un campeón
regresar a octavos de final acabando con
esa maldición día para matar fantasmas
para Francia porque efectivamente
Francia venía de perder contra Dinamarca
en liga de Naciones y también en ese
tristemente recordado mundial de 2002 en
el que cayeron en primera fase después
de ganar en Francia de 1998 también en
ese mundial perdieron contra Dinamarca
Así es Juan interesante el planteamiento
de la selección en francesa pero
volvemos a hablar del grupo c porque en
otro partido de la jornada la selección
de Polonia venció dos goles por 0 a su
similar de Arabia Saudita el partido fue
significativo porque Robert lewandowski
anotó su primer tanto con la casaca
polaca en una copa del mundo fue de
hecho el segundo gol de ese compromiso
pero Juan cómo ese momento para el
jugador polaco que tuvo una que hubiese
sido antes de anotar la Diana quizás el
mejor gol de esta copa del mundo
es tremendo que un goleador como
lewandowski haya marcado hasta hoy su
primer tanto en una copa mundo y lo
vimos emocionarse a lewandowski porque
este gol significa muchísimo para
Polonia hace 2 a 0 que le da la que le
dio la tranquilidad a su equipo contra
Arabia Saudita un Arabia Saudita quien
esta copa mundo está jugando como local
Hoy era un unísono ese estadio lleno de
sábado 10 que venimos diciendo muchos de
ellos vienen en carretera hace un viaje
que puede ser de tres hasta seis horas
incluso a seis horas hasta
riata hasta la capital aproximadamente
mucha decisión entre los saudíes y los
pocos polacos que había hoy en ese
estadio en el estadio de la ciudad de la
educación celebraron esa Victoria para
Polonia Polonia que hizo un
planteamiento muy bueno ese de la mano
sobre todo su mediocentro de aquí
apoyados también en veresinski en un
millik que entró como titular en este
encuentro para también ayudar en defensa
y sobre todo obviamente elevando sí que
hace y se pelea con todos arriba en la
delantera buscando sacar petróleo a las
pelotas que le llega un buen encuentro
el de Po nos deja un grupo c que está
más emocionante que nunca y que seas
igualado con ese grupo B el de
Inglaterra Estados Unidos El de gales y
el de Irán no hablaba Juan en un grupo
que está sumamente parejo sumamente
complicado y que se definirá en la
última fecha pero Octavio triunfo
argentino triunfo polaco ya había ganado
varias Saudita en los papeles
Polonia y Argentina eran los que iban a
disputar este grupo y les toca ahora
enfrentarse en la última fecha que
esperar de este partido exactamente Luis
y en este momento lo sigue siendo
Polonia está en el primer lugar con
cuatro puntos y Argentina en el segundo
con tres por encima de Arabia Saudita
por la diferencia de goles hay que
contar a la gente que en ese último
partido van a jugar Argentina y Polo ni
va a jugar México contra Arabia Saudita
Argentina tiene la posibilidad de ganar
ganando el partido clasificarse primero
sin ningún inconveniente perdiendo
evidentemente va a quedar eliminado pero
empatando pueden darse una serie de
circunstancias de acuerdo a lo que se dé
en el otro partido entre México y Arabia
Saudita para que Argentina incluso
empatando pueda clasificar entonces hoy
argentina se ha quitado ese peso encima
Argentina entró este partido realmente
nervioso realmente sabiendo que si
perdían Y no y no exageración se acababa
la carrera de muchos jugadores en el
seleccionador argentino incluyendo
Leonel Messi entonces la presión Era
realmente fuerte por eso argentina se
sacó ese peso de encima el gol de Messi
y el gol de son Fernández que Enzo
Fernández que es la gran revelación
estrés seleccionado le va a permitir
ahora encarar el partido de otra manera
enfrente va a tener un equipo que tiene
a Robert lewandowsky es cierto pero es
un tipo robotizado es un equipo muy
ordenado que tiene muy poca chispa
individual y que evidentemente no es no
tiene el talento que tiene Argentina
pero que si se ordena muy bien va a ser
un duro día para para el equipo que
dirige Leonel escalón Muchas gracias
Octavio aprovechamos también para
agradecerle a Juana por sus
intervenciones a lo largo de
segmento a continuación una selección de
noticias
la selección de Alemania sigue con su
desafío a la FIFA además tenía incidente
por el uso de brazalete en apoyo a la
comunidad lgbt y q más taparse la boca
para la foto antes de su presentación
frente a Japón los jugadores alemanes no
acudieron a la rueda de prensa previa al
partido contra España la acción podría
acarrear una multa por parte del ente
rector del fútbol
Kevin de bruyne jugador de la selección
de Bélgica se quitó presión e Indicó que
su combinado no está para ganar la copa
del mundo el centrocampista del
Manchester City sustentó su afirmación
diciendo que son demasiados viejos
Bélgica terminó en la tercera posición
en la copa del mundo celebrada en Rusia
el jugador brasileño Richardson autor de
las dos ganas de Brasil en la victoria
frente a Serbia y candidato para el
mejor gol del presente mundial se
solidarizó con las víctimas del atentado
ocurrido en su estado aracruz donde un
atacante a un centro educativo provocó
la muerte de dos profesores y un alumno
a continuación la agenda de partidos
para este domingo
iniciamos revisando la acción del grupo
e si el de Argentina México fue un juego
que paralizó América Latina no le quiero
contar lo que pasará con este grupo
porque la jornada abre con un Japón
contra Costa Rica y en la tarde para
Colombia Perú y Ecuador estarán
enfrentándose Alemania y España Alemania
viene de golear a Costa Rica y Alemania
cayó en su primera presentación frente a
Japón una derrota más y dejaría a los
alemanes fuera del torneo
por el grupo F también habrá acción este
domingo Bélgica estará midiéndose a
Marruecos un triunfo para los europeos
le otorgará la clasificación a la
siguiente etapa en otro Duelo Canadá
estará ritualizando contra Croacia los
canadienses van por su primer triunfo en
la copa del mundo
[Música]